[Music]
in an exclusive cbs news interview
former acting attorney general sally
yates who was fired you recall in a
confrontation with then president trump
over travel bans she's revealing now her
private battle with breast cancer as we
mark breast cancer awareness month we're
pleased to say that yates is now
cancer-free very pleased indeed she says
she continued to do critical work during
her health crisis
yates was diagnosed believe it or not in
2020 around the same time she testified
to congress about the justice
department's investigation of the 2016
trump campaign and russian interference
in the election she also spoke at the
democratic national convention while
fighting her uphill battle behind closed
doors trying to restore her health
here's part now of her conversation with
cbs evening news anchor and managing
editor norah o'donnell
i think about the timing of this last
summer you were testifying before
congress
and speaking at the democratic national
convention
what was it like going through such a
private battle while being a public
person
well you know that was
that was odd um you know i tend to
compartmentalize my life in some ways
and professionally you know much of my
professional life has been somewhat in
the public eye i'm a pretty private
person but this was one of those times
where the personal and the professional
collided
and so it was i think just about five
days before i was to testify in the
senate judiciary committee about the
russia investigation that i got the
final diagnosis that it was invasive
cancer and that's some pretty important
testimony that you were about to give it
was
gates has a lot to say about that senate
hearing and you can see more of nora's
interview tonight on the cbs evening
news and you can go to cbsnews.com right
now to read an exclusive essay that
yates wrote about her experience
fighting breast cancer i mean it's like
another case where you never know the
personal battle a person is fighting as
they are in public well we knew she was
strong to begin with but now it just
exposes a whole different side to this
woman it is mind-blowing to me that in
this day and age with social media and
everything else that people can keep
these types of things private yeah that
says something i'm actually heartened by
that me too
and i've always said that women should
wear capes because they can bear so much
more than they let us know that they're
dealing absolutely
that's for sure